You can now track how your website or
brand shows up in AI search directly in
Word Rocket. This is also very useful
for tracking your competitors and their
AI brand mentions. So, we just head over
to AI visibility and you'll be able to
access this based upon the plan that
you're on. This is a paid feature, so
just depending on the plan that you're
on, depends on the features and the
amounts of AI visibility tracking that
you have. So, we're going to head over
to new target. We're going to give it a
nickname for this specific target. Then
we're going to enter in our domain. Now,
you can also add a brand alias, which is
essentially a nickname for your brand.
Now, if it's a generic nickname like
TMSC, that may not work well because the
AI will actually pull other irrelevant
uh mentions of that search term. So, you
just make sure it's specific and unique
to your brand. Then we can go ahead and
add in our competitors. We can add up to
six competitors and then we're going to
see the platforms in which we're
tracking. Currently, we're only tracking
Chat GPT. We will roll out Perplexity
and other AI search uh places. So, now
once we have created our target, we're
going to go ahead and click scan now.
So, once we click scan now, in a couple
of seconds, we'll be able to get our
visibility score out of 100 and how many
times we're mentioned. So, we see here
we have a visibility score of 84 out of
100. We're just going to click into this
to get more information. So, we can see
how many mentions we have. So, we have
101 mentions.
Then we have the AI search volume, which
is the monthly AI searches across the
questions where your brand's appears. It
tells you how much uh demand there is
for these search terms. And then you get
a share of voice. So, depending on how
your competitors are, you get a share of
voice as how your website stacks up to
your competitors in terms of the overall
niche. So, if we head over to Chat GPT,
we click into it, we can actually see
the search queries. We can see the
answers that are cited, and we can see
um
where our brand is showing up in
ChatGPT. So, for example, what does an
early leukemia rash look like? We can
see here that the Minor Surgery Center
is showing up for this specific search
term.
Does violin cause carpal tunnel? What
are the healthiest earrings to wear?
What does a leukemia rashes look like?
So on and so forth. So, we can see here
that this is very very related to our
niche. We know for a fact that this
information is correct. But, if you want
to double-check it,
for example, I went ahead and put in
what does an early leukemia rash look
like in ChatGPT.
And if you scroll down to our resources,
we can see that the Minor Surgery Center
was actually shown up for this specific
search query. So, we can see that the
information is correct, and it is
up-to-date.
So, again, there's a lot of different
searches here. You can click the pages
that AI consulted with while doing this
research to get the actual links of what
the AI used. So, for example, we just
clicked one of those links there, and we
can see here that this is the Minor
Surgery Center. So, this was about does
violin cause carpal tunnel? So, you can
see here that this article here was
indexed and cited by ChatGPT. And of
course, we use our tool Word Rocket to
write this article. So, if you're
thinking that AI-generated content or
Word Rocket does not get cited by AI, we
can clearly see that this article here
that was written using our tool Word
Rocket
actually gets cited and shows up in AI
search. So, again, we'll be able to see
the search term and the AI searches
estimated per month for that specific
key term. So, that's only the beginning
of what you can do with the AI search
visibility. There's also the improvement
section. So, this gives you a
personalized ranked list of fixes that
you can do to help you improve your AI
visibility. So, I'm just going to click
that and come back once it's finished.
Now, prompts allows you to actually
track specific prompts. So, if I wanted
to track, you know, skin cancer Toronto
clinics,
then I can enter in that specific
prompt, click plus, and this is going to
be tracked. So, week after week, I'm
going to be able to go ahead and see how
we're stacking up when it comes to this
specific search term. We saw that our
improvements were now finished, so we
can now see what we can improve upon.
So, this is telling us that our brand is
being mentioned by Healthline, but maybe
they haven't actually linked back to our
website. So, I definitely go ahead and
look into this and see what we can do to
get this citation um or or link back
from Healthline. So, we see we can
create another page here. So, a lipoma
treatment update page targeting 2026
trends. So, question, what is the new
treatment for lipomas in 2026? This is a
search topic that people are searching
up. So, this is an idea of what we can
create. So, counter
torontodermatology.com
on lipoma rash queries. So, it's telling
us what we can do based upon our
competitor. Develops scar tissue
coverage guide. Expand on specific
content here. Create an armpit lymph
diagnostic tool. Right? So, like this is
just amazing amazing intel that we're
getting back here of things in which we
can do to improve our AI search. Add
schema markup. Audit and strengthen
Medical News Today relationship. Create
hair removal cream and moles safety
guide. So, again, really really good
actionable data-driven improvements that
we're getting back. So, we looked at the
prompts, which allows you to search up
our prompts. We also have an on-page AI
readiness audit. So, this is going to go
out and audit your
website, and tell you how ready or how
not ready your website is for AI search.
So, you get a score of 92 out of out of
100. We see if your LLMs.txt is
included, your FAQ schema, or your
schema.org. And then you see
improvements that you need to make.
There's also pitch,
um, which allows you to find
opportunities to get cited. So, for
example, if there's big players in your
niche that allow for guest posting, we
can reach out to them to get some link
backs or link back to our articles to
help increase the the chances that we
can actually get cited. So again, we see
the mentions all in one place under
their mentions, you can quickly go
through them.
And then we have our competitors. So we
can see
how much mentions our competitors have
in comparison to us.
And under sources, we're going to see
the sources actually mentioning your
brand. So these are the sources that you
need to reach out to build a better
relationship to see, you know, if they
can cite you more, or ways in which you
guys can work together because they're
already mentioning your brand. So as you
can see, it's a very, very in-depth, um,
AI search visibility tracker, and
everything is data-driven and actionable
to help you improve your AI visibility.
So if you guys want to try this feature
for yourself, just head over to
app.wordtracker.ai/ai-visibility.
I'll leave a link below today's video.
Hope that you guys enjoyed this one. If
you have any questions, let me know in
the comments below. I'll see you in the
next video. Take care.